my delicious pan fried pork chops with
sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sound peppers
go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look that's what you want
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes
the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelise the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose
great for sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fish on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak in
you now start to see glistening in a way
that it's starting to caramelize sugar's
working beautifully
that's ready for the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three
minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic
just roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
point the knife down
flip through this seasoned beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is gonna stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
and the garlic take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over look at that beautiful
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste
so i'm sort of speeding up the cooking
process at the same time i'm keeping the
pork chop really nice and moist
and now look at the color that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side 30 seconds from now they're going
to be medium so i'm going to take them
out and let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
[Music]
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is gonna shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour peppers
my next recipe can be kept on tap in the
fridge for weeks on end and is
guaranteed to liven up any quick meal
spicy chutney
with chutney standing by in the fridge
you can always add that special little
touch to a simple supper prove that
thinking ahead always pays off
pan on start toasting those spices keep
the pan nice and low cumin very aromatic
very fragrant and it's almost like a
light spice
next nice little coriander seeds
coriander in now you're going to get a
bit of heat in the chutney mustard seeds
well smaller than coriander seeds but so
much more powerful mustard seeds in
now
curry leaves
they don't actually smell much dry but
the flavor they give off is
extraordinary kodi's in
really important not to burn them
otherwise you'll
have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
low the secret is sort of toasting them
so it releases that oil and intensifies
the spice touch of
salt and then a couple small powerful
chilies keep them whole
no one's gonna eat them but it gives
that real nice burst of heat
now let them toast gently there we're
not gonna chop the onion we're gonna
grate it
why
because it sort of breaks down to a
really nice puree in the chutney when
you're grated hold the root in the palm
of your hand
and just push
nice long
grates
i want those nice long shards
look i've almost got a nice sort of
onion puree but it's nice and clear
a touch of olive oil
spices nicely toasted onions in
[Music]
three nice cloves of garlic lightly
crushed them
[Music]
lay it nice and flat and just slice the
garlic
nice thin slices
garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelised beautifully will really reap
rewards in the long run
tamarind paste
and sugar in with the sugar first three
nice tablespoons of sugar
that will give a really nice syrup
effect
sort of nice rich syrupy texture
to the chutney
tamarind paste
you can get tamarind paste in most delis
and the big supermarkets
it's really nice thickening asian but it
gives that tartness the chutney and it's
sort of rich sugary spicy
next in with my coconut add four nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body
and a really nice texture to the chutney
cook that coconut out and now add the
carrot
grated
the carrot just gives the chutney a
really nice sort of crunch
but also helps to sort of cool down the
spice
carrots
in the water comes out the carrot
flavors the chutney beautifully but
gives that nice sort of vibrant bright
color to it as well
and grating it almost sort of it cooks
instantly but i want a bit of texture
through here turn down the gas and just
let that simmer for five minutes
if the carrots aren't that moist and
juicy then put a couple of tablespoons
of water in there to help it along
now
just cook that out
for five minutes
just as those carrots start going nice
and soft don't overcook them you want
that nice texture in there slightly
spicy slightly sweet
gas off
keep those chillies in there for that
it's beautiful
nice and gooey delicious and
ready to go in this jar as that sits in
the fridge
just gets better
and better and better
i love to eat this chutney with
cold meats or even cold fish but with
ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of living up the
ham
just sort of roll it up
get a nice spoon of chutney i mean it
looks fantastic
chutney onto the plate
and serve and that is a
nice little
gem in the fridge that is worth prepping
in advance for
first off start with the dough
tip 500 grams of strong bread flour into
a mixing bowl and add 20 grams of
semolina
that gives the vacation it's sort of
rustic charm
now there's one thing for catcher needs
it's really good seasoning you can't
season bread after it's baked so it's
got to go in right at the very beginning
sprinkling 15 grams of dried yeast
take some warm water
and then 50 mils of olive oil top of
that water
that gives it this really nice silky
rich texture
make a little well
mix up that yeast water
and oil in
start off with your fingers keep your
fingers nice and open it's like a little
sort of whisk going in there i'm looking
for a really nice sort of relaxed
dough
now that's just starting to come
together touch more water with oil in
there give a little swirl
and then again
the secret is to sort of knead it gently
don't overwork it
it's a sort of
easy bread to make a nice one to start
off with when you're making bread for
the first time
basically kneading means just knit it
together
just hanging
lightly flour
your board
and let's just knead that focaccia into
a nice smooth dough
make sure you don't over add
too much flour otherwise it sort of
dries out the dough
something quite
magical about making bread you can
switch off
and lose yourself
my first job for a three-mission style
establishment was a baker i was 22 years
of age i usually start at midnight i was
under such a tight schedule
one o'clock white bread then two o'clock
brown bread
three o'clock sourdough four o'clock
cheese bread
five o'clock proof bake
six o'clock crack them open and taste it
was amazing
beautiful yeah
looks stunning it hasn't even risen yet
leave your dough to rise in a warm place
until it's doubled in size we call this
proving
[Music]
that
beautiful a lot of chefs sort of need it
for the second time but i'm looking for
a really nice light aerated for catcher
take your tray
a touch of olive oil in there season it
at the bottom really important
that's the exciting thing about focaccia
you've got that really nice sort of
salty top
and salty bottom
and just with a touch of olive oil
on your hands
gently push that in and almost massage
it into the corners it's possible to put
sort of olives and tomatoes and garlic
through the dough but it never really
allows the dough to sort of aerate
properly when you put so much
ingredients in
i'm gonna stick mine on top use your
finger and sort of just push them in
salt on top
some pepper on top as well
i want some nice
fresh amazing rosemary just hold the
stalk and just pull off
and then just sprinkle down generous in
the rosemary
really important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the fuckache
finish it off before it goes in
with a little drizzle of olive oil
so it
almost sinks in those little pockets of
flavor olive tomato rosemary and olive
oil
into the
oven bake your focaccia at 200 degrees
for 30 to 35 minutes
[Music]
smells delicious
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is
you can't beat a nice warm fresh slice
of home-cooked focaccia it's rustic
charming and it's the perfect way
to start baking making homemade for
catcher
it's so addictive
you